pleasure to see you this show is
the one i was most looking forward to i
have to tell you and it's cool that like
with your character people talk about oh
i want to be in the mcu i want to be
this hero or this villain
but there's this whole i guess now a
multiverse of characters
that you have to play that don't
necessarily fit neatly entirely entirely
into those
definitions how does it feel for you to
be able to expand upon
the stories in the way that you're doing
well that's what i love about the show
and i think that's what we get to do
with a character like loki who is
essentially an anti-hero
and we're following and rooting for him
is that essential question of
yes nobody fits into a box you know
nobody is 100 good nobody is 100
bad you know they're the the spectrum of
what it means to be a villain or a hero
you know is is a bit more of a gray area
in loki
and i think that's really exciting to
explore and especially
coming into the tva the time variance
authority which
you know my character oversees uh is is
a really special new perspective on the
mcu and a whole new facet of the
universe
um for fans to see how
how exciting is it for you to be like
the boss
in this show you know what i mean like
you're having meetings with owen wilson
but you're
like you know you're you're in charge of
everything
i know it's it's pretty great i mean
when kate herron pitched it to me you
know
she's she's a judge she's the boss you
know she she approves all of these
missions that
uh you know mobius owen wilson's
character goes
on she has the final say um for me
that's really exciting it's a bit of a
departure for me to be able to play such
an authoritative
and respected character so so i've
really relished it i'm not gonna lie
when you are part of the mcu and you get
onto the set of another show or another
project
are there cast members going to like yo
give me the goods like give me the goods
on loki what's coming next
does that happen to you um you know it's
funny i went straight to another job in
the uk
which was such a different different
style different genre so we didn't
really talk about it and
obviously my lips have been sealed you
know not wanting to spoil
anything um for the show so um
so yeah but i've definitely got really
good brownie points with my friend's um
seven-year-old son who is
the most excited to see this show
a whole new demographic of um of
coolness from him
that's the one that matters the most
though for sure yeah
who would you say is um maybe the
biggest
marvel nerd among your cast mates
well i mean it would have to be tom
because he's been playing this character
for 10 years so he's not just a nerd
he's sort of an authority because he's
he's he's lived it he's lived and
breathed it you know and i think that
that is
also been great for the rest of us who
are newbies joining
um to know that um you know we can just
check with tom about
things like an encyclopedia of knowledge
if there's ever any question marks about
you know
anything in the in in the multiverse or
or anything like that
so um so that's been great to sort of
have him as our our leader
that's awesome yes he he he definitely
knows
that's for sure uh it's been such a
pleasure thank you so much
hope to talk to you soon thank you